Ahora, por supuesto, la democracia ateniense excluía a demasiados.
A las mujeres, los migrantes y, por supuesto, los esclavos.
Pero sería un error
desestimar la importancia de la antigua democracia ateniense
sobre la base de quién se excluye.
Lo que era más pertinente,
y sigue siéndolo sobre la antigua democracia ateniense,
es la inclusión de los trabajadores pobres,
que no solo tenían el derecho a la libre expresión,
sino lo más importante, sobre todo,
adquirieron los derechos de los juicios políticos
a los que se les concedía la misma importancia
en la toma de decisiones sobre los asuntos de Estado.
Por supuesto, la democracia ateniense no duró mucho.
Como una vela que arde brillantemente, se quemó rápidamente.
Y de hecho,
las democracias liberales de hoy no tienen raíces en la antigua Atenas.
Tienen sus raíces en la Carta Magna,
en la Gloriosa Revolución de 1688,
de hecho, en la Constitución de Estados Unidos.
Mientras que la democracia ateniense se centra en el ciudadano sin dueño
y el empoderamiento de los trabajadores pobres,
nuestras democracias liberales se basan en la tradición de la Carta Magna,
que era, después de todo, una carta para amos.
Y, en efecto, la democracia liberal solo surgió cuando fue posible
separar completamente la esfera política de la esfera económica,
con el fin de limitar el proceso democrático
plenamente en la esfera política, dejando la esfera económica,
el mundo empresarial si lo prefieren,
como una zona libre de democracia.
En nuestras democracias actuales,
esta separación de lo económico de la esfera política,
justo cuando comenzó,
dio lugar a una inexorable lucha épica entre ambas,
con la esfera económica colonizando la esfera política,
devorando su poder.
¿Se han preguntado por qué los políticos no son lo que solían ser?
No es porque su ADN haya degenerado.
(Risas)
Más bien es porque uno puede estar en el gobierno hoy y no en el poder,
porque el poder ha migrado desde la política a la esfera económica,
que es independiente.
Ciertamente,
hablé de mi pelea contra el capitalismo.
Si lo piensan bien,
es un poco como una población de depredadores,
que tienen tanto éxito en diezmar a la presa con la que se alimentan
que al final se mueren de hambre.
Del mismo modo,
la esfera económica ha colonizando y canibalizado la esfera política
hasta tal punto que está socavándose a sí misma,
provocando crisis económicas.
El poder corporativo es cada vez mayor,
los bienes políticos se están devaluando,
la desigualdad aumenta,
la demanda agregada está cayendo
y los empresarios tienen miedo de invertir el dinero de sus corporaciones.
Entre más triunfa el capitalismo en quitar el demos de la democracia,
más altos son los picos gemelos
y mayor es la pérdida de recursos humanos
y de riqueza de la humanidad.
Está claro que si esto es cierto,
debemos reunir las esferas políticas y económicas
y es mejor hacerlo con el demos en el control,
como en la antigua Atenas, excepto sin los esclavos
o la exclusión de las mujeres y los migrantes.
Esto no es una idea original.
La izquierda marxista tenía esa idea hace 100 años
y no le fue muy bien, ¿verdad?
La lección que hemos aprendido de la debacle soviética
es que solo con un milagro los trabajadores pobres se reempoderarán
como lo eran en la antigua Atenas,
sin crear nuevas formas de brutalidad y desperdicios.
Pero hay una solución:
eliminar a los trabajadores pobres.
El capitalismo lo hace al sustituir
los trabajadores con salarios bajos por autómatas, androides, robots.
El problema es
que mientras las esferas de la economía y la política sean independientes,
la automatización hace que los picos gemelos sean más altos,
los desechos más elevados
y los conflictos sociales más profundos,
incluso,
pronto, creo,
en lugares como China.
Tenemos que volver a reconfigurar,
tenemos que reagrupar lo económico y lo político,
y será mejor hacerlo democratizando la esfera reunificada,
no sea que nos encontremos con una hiperautocracia vigilante loca
que haga que Matrix, la película, parezca un documental.
(Risas)
La pregunta no es si el capitalismo sobrevivirá
a las innovaciones tecnológicas que están surgiendo.
Una pregunta más interesante
es si el capitalismo será reemplazado por algo parecido a una distopía Matrix
o algo mucho más cercano a una sociedad como Star Trek,
donde las máquinas sirven a los seres humanos
y los humanos gastan sus energías en explorar el universo
y disfrutando de largos debates sobre el significado de la vida
de una manera antigua, como en un ágora de Atenas de alta tecnología.
Creo que podemos darnos el lujo de ser optimistas.
Pero ¿qué haría falta,
cómo sería
tener esta utopía Star Trek en lugar de la distopía Matrix?
En términos prácticos,
les compartiré brevemente,
un par de ejemplos.
A nivel de la empresa,
imaginen un mercado de capitales,
donde ganan capital a medida que trabajan,
y donde su capital los sigue de un trabajo a otro,
de una compañía a otra,
y la empresa,
con quien sea que trabajen en ese momento,
es propiedad exclusiva de aquellos que trabajen ahí en ese momento.
Entonces todos los ingresos por el capital, a partir de las ganancias,
y el propio concepto de trabajo asalariado se vuelven obsoletos.
No hay separación entre aquellos que poseen, pero no trabajan en la empresa
y los que trabajan pero no son propietarios de la empresa;
no más guerra entre el capital y el trabajo;
ninguna brecha entre inversión y ahorro;
de hecho, no hay imponentes picos gemelos.
En el ámbito de la economía política global,
imaginen por un momento
que nuestras monedas nacionales tienen un tipo de cambio de libre flotación,
con una moneda universal, global, digital,
emitida por el Fondo Monetario Internacional,
el G-20,
en beneficio de toda la humanidad.
E imaginen además
que todo el comercio internacional se realiza en esta moneda,
vamos a llamarla "cosmos",
en unidades de cosmos,
con todos los gobiernos acordando a pagar a un fondo común
una suma de cosmos proporcional al déficit comercial del país,
o al superávit comercial de un país.
E imaginen que ese fondo se usa para invertir en tecnologías verdes,
especialmente en partes del mundo donde la financiación es escasa.
Esta no es una idea nueva.
Es lo que, efectivamente, John Maynard Keynes propuso
en 1944 en la Conferencia de Bretton Woods.
El problema es
que en ese entonces no tenían la tecnología para llevarla a cabo.
Ahora la tenemos,
especialmente en el contexto de una esfera político-económico reunificada.
El mundo que estoy describiéndoles
es al mismo tiempo libertario,
en que se da prioridad a las personas empoderadas,
marxista,
ya que se ha confinado al basurero de la historia
la división entre capital y trabajo,
y keynesiano,
keynesiano global.
Pero por encima de todo, es un mundo en el que
vamos a ser capaces de imaginar una auténtica democracia.
¿Sería el amanecer del mundo?
¿O vamos a caer en una distopía Matrix?
La respuesta está en la decisión política que tomemos colectivamente.
Es nuestra elección,
y será mejor que lo hagamos democráticamente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Yanis,
tú te describiste como marxista libertario.
¿Cuál es la relevancia del análisis de Marx hoy en día?
YV: Bueno, si lo que acabo de decir tiene alguna relevancia,
entonces Marx es relevante.
Porque la idea de reunificar la política y la económica,
si nosotros no lo hacemos,
entonces la innovación tecnológica va a crear
una caída masiva de la demanda agregada,
lo que Larry Summers llamaba estancamiento secular.
Con esta crisis migratoria de una parte del mundo,
como hoy en día,
desestabilizará no solo nuestras democracias,
sino también en el mundo emergente que no es tan dado a la democracia liberal.
Así que si este análisis es importante, entonces Marx es absolutamente relevante.
Pero también lo es Hayek,
es por eso que soy un marxista libertario,
y también Keynes,
así que por eso estoy totalmente confundido.
(Risas)
BG: En efecto y posiblemente también lo estamos.
(Aplausos)
YV: Si no estás confundido, no estás pensando, ¿cierto?
BG: Es algo muy de filósofos griegos decir eso.
YV: Lo dijo Einstein, en realidad.
BG: Durante tu charla mencionaste a Singapur y China,
y ayer en la cena con los oradores,
expresaste una opinión muy fuerte sobre cómo Occidente mira a China.
¿Quieres compartir eso?
YV: Bueno, hay un alto grado de hipocresía.
En nuestras democracias liberales, tenemos una apariencia de democracia.
Es porque hemos limitado, como decía en mi charla,
la democracia a la esfera política,
dejando la esfera donde está toda la acción,
la esfera económica,
como una zona completamente libre de democracia.
En un sentido,
si se me permite ser provocador,
China hoy en día está más cerca de la Gran Bretaña del siglo XIX.
Porque recuerda,
solemos asociar el liberalismo con la democracia,
eso es un error, históricamente.
El liberalismo, liberal, es como John Stuart Mill.
John Stuart Mill era particularmente escéptico sobre el proceso democrático.
Lo que estamos viendo ahora en China es un proceso muy similar
al que tuvimos en Gran Bretaña durante la Revolución Industrial,
especialmente la transición de la primera a la segunda.
Y castigar a China
por hacer lo que Occidente hizo en el siglo XIX,
huele a hipocresía.
BG: Estoy seguro de que mucha gente aquí se pregunta sobre tu experiencia
como Ministro de Finanzas de Grecia a principios de este año.
YV: Lo veía venir.
BG: Sí.
BG: Seis meses después,
¿cómo vez la primera mitad del año?
YV: Extremadamente interesante, desde un punto de vista personal,
y muy decepcionante,
porque tuvimos la oportunidad de reiniciar la Eurozona.
No solo Grecia, la zona euro.
Para alejarnos de la complacencia
y la negación constante de que hay una falla,
y hay una falla masiva en la arquitectura
en la Eurozona,
que amenaza, masivamente, a la totalidad del proceso de la Unión Europea.
Tuvimos una oportunidad con base en el programa griego
que, por cierto,
fue el primer programa en manifestar esa negación,
para poner las cosas bien.
Y, desafortunadamente,
los poderes de la Eurozona,
en el Eurogrupo,
optaron por mantener la negación.
Pero ya sabes lo que pasa.
Es la experiencia de la Unión Soviética.
Cuando intentas mantener vivo
un sistema económico que arquitectónicamente no puede sobrevivir,
a través de la voluntad política y a través de autoritarismo,
puedes tener éxito en extenderla,
pero cuando se produce el cambio
sucede muy abrupta y catastróficamente.
BG: ¿Qué tipo de cambio prevés?
YV: Bueno, no hay duda
de que si no cambiamos la arquitectura de la Eurozona,
esa zona no tiene futuro.
BG: ¿Cometiste errores cuando eras Ministro de Finanzas?
YV: Todos los días.
BG: ¿Por ejemplo? YV: Cualquiera que mira hacia atrás...
(Aplausos)
No, pero en serio.
Si hay algún ministro de hacienda o de cualquier otra cosa,
que dice al cabo de seis meses en un trabajo,
especialmente en una situación estresante,
que no se ha equivocado, es gente peligrosa.
Por supuesto que cometí errores.
El mayor error fue firmar la solicitud
para la ampliación de un contrato de préstamo
en el final de febrero.
Me imaginaba
que había un interés genuino en el lado de los acreedores
para encontrar un terreno común.
Y no lo había.